I mean, using the right for two months now, why am I not better yet?
This was a question from somebody who asked me thoroughly, and I put it on here because they also
asked if about their supplements. They've only been taking their supplements for a few months
as well. I think it's unfair to yourself to have unrealistic expectations.
Can a person have miraculous results in even two weeks of using the right? Yes, because we've
seen it. We've actually seen people after just a few days of using the right, having miraculous
results. I mean, their symptoms go on away. But you have to be a realist too. So a lot of people
are very optimistic. People are very pessimistic. I tend to be very realistic. So I don't want to be
pie in the sky giving hope that is unwarranted. We've seen literal miracles with the right,
but sometimes it takes a long time. With my own cancer, it took me a year and a half to
really see a difference in my cancer, even although I was using the right on a daily basis even,
all night and during the day at work. So it took a long time for things to change.
Also, you've got to look at, you know, most people, you know, the old saying room wasn't built
in the day. You didn't get cancer overnight, even though you think I was healthier than an ox.
My whole life and also I have cancer. What is the cost? Now, we can't have, and we've seen post COVID
vaccine. People with very rapidly progressing cancers. But for the most part,
the cancers would grow in a person's body for a number of years before it gets to the point
where you end up with a diagnosis. So you have to give yourself some time for your body to heal,
and you have to be willing to make the changes. So if you're not willing to make lifestyle changes,
if you're not staying on the top of taking your supplements, if you're not taking your right,
I had somebody ask a question. It was about a year ago. They're upset that they were getting sick.
And I asked them, are they using the right? I tell you, I've had this same answer,
at least a dozen times or more throughout my career, how you've been doing. I see you haven't even
purchased any supplements. Are you getting them somewhere else? That's fine with me, but are you taking them?
No, I haven't been taking them. I haven't been feeling good. I haven't been taking them. Okay,
how you doing with using the right? Well, I haven't really been using it lately. Then I get the right
back, and I can tell when I look at it, and I go into some settings on your computer how often
everybody's been actually using the right, who when I see that they haven't used the right for seven
months, it's sad. Or we have a patient that passes away, and their spouse sends the right back to us,
and Godates it to give it to somebody that is less fortunate. And that's a very nice thing, but when
we get that right back, and I see they haven't used it for a year, it just makes me sad.
If you're not doing the things that you've committed to doing, and we ask everybody before they start
with us, make sure you pray about this is what you're supposed to do. If you pray about what this is,
this is what you're supposed to do, then if you're committing to doing it, and you're paying us money
for a piece of equipment, by all means, you know, I really want you to be using it. I don't want
people to, I mean, it's a sad thing when we buy a treadmill, and it functions as a clothes hanger
in the corner of our bedroom. But this is the right machine that can save your life. So don't stop
doing it. Continue to do the right things. Your faith can't be in the right machine, nor can it be in
your diet, nor can it be in your positive, mental, energy. Your faith has to be in Jesus Christ.
And he's the one who's going to ultimately bring to conclusion the conclusion that he desires. But if
we're not doing our part, then, then, say about us. So we need to be doing our part, doing the right thing,
and continuing with what God has set our feet to in order for us to expect any results once a
month. So it takes time. We've had people start out on a nutritional protocol, and then they quit
after two months, and say, well, this is the work I'm going to change to something else. It's like,
you believe it, taking these for two months, you know, what are you expecting? And so we have to be
realists that things take time, and you have to be committed to things, committed to doing the right
things. I'm not saying that we don't tweak things, and change things, and protocols change,
and nutrition changes, but you have to stick to it then.